[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this November you gotta get out and vote
it's all about democracy y'all your boat
gets counted with the rest of the boats
in the country and they get sent off to
the Electoral College what's that the
Electoral College are a bunch of
officials who do the voting for us so in
case we elect the wrong person they can
fix that [ __ ]
hold up
who the hell are these people well no
one knows for sure but whoever they is
they the folks who actually do the real
voting after we do our pretend vote yeah
power to the people oh the god
you're telling me our votes don't matter
our votes are like suggestions so this
November we should yeah
good evening my fellow Americans now
before I begin
I just want to say that I know a lot of
people out there seem to think that I
don't get angry
that's just not true I get angry a lot
it's just the way I express passion is
different from most
so just so there's no more confusion
we've hired Luther here to be my anger
translator Luther
first off concerning the recent
developments in the Middle Eastern
region I just want to reiterate our
unflinching support for all people and
their right to a democratic process hey
all y'all dictators out there keep
messing around and see what happens just
see what happens watch also to the
governments of Iran and North Korea we
once again urge you to discontinue your
uranium enrichment program hey Mahmoud
Kim Jong I think I already Untold both
y'all 86 [ __ ] imma come over there
and do it for y'all please test me and
see what happens on the domestic front
I just want to say to my critics I hear
your voices and I'm aware of your
concerns so maybe you can chill the hell
out for like a second then maybe I keep
[ __ ] Michael's for everybody
including members of the Tea Party don't
even get me started on these Muppets
right here I want to assure you that we
will be looking for new compromises with
the GOP and lamonts ahead and you know
these gonna say no before I even
suggestions now I know a lot of folks
say that I haven't done a good job at
communicating my accomplishments to the
public because
don't listen uh uh since being in office
we've created three million new jobs 3
million new
we ended the war in Iraq
these achievements should serve as a
reminder that I am on your side
I'm not my intentions as your president
are coming from the right place they're
coming from Hawaii which is where I'm
from which is in the United States of
America y'all okay this is ridiculous I
have a birth certificate I have a birth
certificate I have a hot diggity
Microsoft birth certificate you dumbass
crackers okay Luther yeah dial it back
Luther damn in conclusion
last night I had a conversation with
Michelle
nope I did not say that I did not say
that
without ball down the street Brothers
all take a knee Honey's dropping their
G's wanting pieces of me cause I run
this whole block with these Rhymes in
this Glide make this whole damn hood
tick this my town I'm the talk [ __ ] of
the water I'm the boss and the King it's
kissing my ass and [ __ ] kissing my
ring what's up
you know it's true
[Music]
I'm the leader of the Free World
here is your white wine thank you you
are welcome hey Pete a little uh a
little thirsty tonight
yeah super thirsty Pete this is her
racer all right so this is uh Pete
Harissa just got back from Africa oh
Africa
uh anyways uh where was I oh the AUC oh
right so this conflict is exactly the
reason the African Union commission was
put in place to address the organization
of African Unity certainly wasn't going
to do anything exactly and in Costa's La
mini Zuma wants to do anything about
bangui she's certainly been quiet about
it the worst part about fungi is that no
one knows what's going on we look at
right next door the South Sudan here's
the thing everybody just thinks that
it's like it's the damn Lion King over
there you know Lion King
excuse me
it's not the Lion King
exactly
I mean what do people think hey
a baboon is gonna hold a lion cub
over a rock up to the sun while all the
little animals sing
[Music]
anyway
um something else I wanted to mention is
they have the Manpower because Amazon
has 25 000 troops just sitting there in
Somalia it's not a three animated hyena
situation that doesn't make any sense
the bad guy isn't scar
over there
um yeah yeah that's right it's not like
scars the bad guy huh well I mean you
know the truth is no one knows who to
blame because in reality Amazon doesn't
have that much control I don't like
Simba
oh like Simba he had no control over
well he was plucked out from his home
and went on a whole journey before he
came back and was just in the middle of
a war really had nothing to do with him
you know Pete I'd be really interested
in hearing your thoughts on the un's
policies in East Africa
Hakuna Matata
unbelievable yes
yeah that sums it up perfect ly
there's so much work still to be done
yes that's what I was saying isn't going
to go in many years so many years circle
of life
exactly that's really brilliant
I remember about brilliant let's dial it
back I'm just a man okay uh I'm gonna
I'm gonna go get some uh some hors
d'oeuvres okay no need to announce it
[Music]
what are your thoughts on the Middle
East
Aladdin
yeah
wasn't that the turn for our polling
station uh well I know young man uh see
we we know a shorter route to Europe
to our Democratic polling station you
know how us Democrats like a shortcut
like government spending to prop up the
economy nothing more we love than those
uh Federal programs
you two are Democrats aren't you what
of course we are
whatever all I know is my polling place
closed in 15 minutes why that would be
terrible awful I mean how are you going
to elect tax and spend politicians if
you can't vote
it's hard enough to vote with all those
voter ID laws
Republicans
I know I'm just like girls
in fact I would take their hard-fought
principles and not shove it right up
there
we seem to be driving in circles
uh don't worry we're almost there
look
it appears we've hit somebody we should
get out and help him
on my leg oh my legs
I am pissed what I'm royally pissed now
although it was only this one man's
fault I will be using all of your tax
dollars to get healthy thanks to the
Affordable Health Care Act I know it
doesn't seem fair but that's supposedly
the law of the land down there but I've
heard you don't look that hurt
why y'all wearing those same leather
jackets
and those dad jeans disperse
black Republican [ __ ]
good evening my fellow Americans now
before we begin I'd like to once again
introduce you to my anger translator
Luther hi
now this November I want each and every
one of you to ask yourselves what has
changed in the last four years who
killed
what is my Administration accomplished
do we accomplish killing America's
biggest enemy uh check did that boom in
2011 alone we created more jobs than
George W bush did in all eight years of
his office except for Osama Bin Laden
Hunter because that job don't exist
anymore because I went over there and I
killed him in his face we helped make
Health Care accessible to more Americans
than ever before I'm sorry what'd you
say uh Your World Trade Center hurts
then why don't you take two dead bin
ladens and call me in the morning [ __ ]
this election make the decision that you
think best serves the future of this
country or you
you quit
I plan to run a Clean Campaign
one based on the issues and the
accomplishments of my Administration but
I'm going to tell you right now if the
Republicans if they had caught Osama Bin
Laden they wouldn't even pay Alex man
they just put a crown on his head and
give him a castle and it's called the
king of America Anatomy
all right all right just you know bring
it down a notch there come on let the
menu straight up out of control brother
well uh it's not that bad okay don't
beat yourself up it's okay excuse me
no Luther you can't say that word oh
actually it says right here I can say it
whenever I want
I guess I can say it too
good night
come on
hello
and welcome to the fifth annual meeting
of the Tallahassee black Republicans now
I'm pissed
royally pissed last November Barack
Obama was re-elected president
and the black vote went almost entirely
to him
we're not getting our message out
Miss Lee
the Republican party is and should be
the only home for black voters now
people think
the black voters are a monolith
we're not a monolith
in fact black Republicans alone are an
extremely diverse group of people
now to speak more on diversity I present
tonight's speaker
Mr Douglas Jackson
[Applause]
now I'm not going to sugarcoat it I'm
pissed I am royally pissed
the liberal media thinks that
republicanism is not for black people
now you tell me what about fiscal
responsibility
a strong National Defense and limited
government is unappealing to black
people we're not a model left
we come in all different shapes and
sizes
now who here like to come to this Podium
and speak about the diversity amongst
black
Republicans
gentlemen we have a real treat today a
gentleman who is a little bit eccentric
a little bit outside of the box if you
will
but I can't think of a better person to
speak on diversity amongst black
Republicans than this gentleman right
here all the way from Orlando my good
friend Arthur Washington
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
thank you for the introduction brother
Douglas
thank you for being here brother Arthur
however I am
pissed
royally pissed indeed indeed Democrats
think they have a right to all the black
peoples but that's not the case we are
not a monolith
Democrats may be cool but they ain't
practical there you go
Republicans are practical black people
are practical
come and think of it
get those pants I think black
Republicans are pretty cool
not to mention very diverse excuse me
gentlemen uh sorry to interrupt
someone's white wife is here to pick
them up
what's her name Emily uh she was white
okay
thank you
good evening my fellow Americans now as
you know sometimes during the chaos of a
presidential campaign it's easy to
forget the beauty of the democratic
process
Ed by a bunch of [ __ ] ass billionaire
this is my anger translator Luther who I
thought had the day off
what are you doing here Luther
anyway I think that everybody needs to
take a moment to appreciate that our
political system truly works unless
Romney wins and then is broke
and despite the heated rhetoric of a
campaign there's always a place for
civil discourse as long as you got a few
million dollars lying around so you can
counteract all the negative
role in all you evil [ __ ] with
your slimy ass super Pacs y'all don't
Pocahontas next with a sugar stick y'all
slap Frankenstein right in the boats man
and you know what after I win this I'm
taking all y'all down
thank you and I'll see you all on the
campaign Trail and when you give me your
babies to kiss please clean their
diapers all right cause I ain't trying
to kiss no poop just wash the ass
you know just wash their ass
it's true
you should wash the ass
[Music]